الرئيس قيس سعيد وايضا جزء من البرلمان
بتهمه المعارضه بالاستنجاد بالخارج ما
الدليل على انه بيستنجدوا بالخارج اليست
هذه حجه
لاحاله من لا نريد المشاركه معهم
على الى الخلف
وحجه مستخدمه كثيره
نحن يعني نرى يوميا العديد
يلتجئون الى يعني الجهات الاجنبيه
للاستقوابها وبالرغم من ذلك يتمتعون بكل
الحريه في بلادنا ولم تقع متابعتهم قضائيا
من اجل ذلك ولكن سياسيا هذا يا شيء ثابت
انهم يستنجدون بمنظمات اجنبيه قصد التاثير
على الوظيفه التنفيذيه وعلى
سلطه القرار في تونس
واعتقد وان من اوقد الاولويات بالنسبه لنا
هو دفاعا استقلاليه قرارنا السيادي
وبالتالي
هذا المسع الذي
اتبعوه سوف لن يجديهم نفعا بل بالعكس
عليهم ان يبتعدوا
يعلموا كل العلم وان المشاكلنا تحل داخليا
بين افراد الشعب التونسي ما رايك
الفعل الخارجيه حول الوضع في تونس
هناك ردود اعتقد وانها ناتجه على عدم
درايه بحقيقه الامور في البلاد وناتجه عن
الدعايه المضاده وربما عن شبكه العلاقات
التي يتمتع بها كل من يعارض هذا التوجه
الجديد في البلاد وعلي يتحال يعني نحن
باتصال بكل من يريد معرفه الحقيقه في
بلادنا واستقبالهم
واتلاحهم على حقيقه الاوضاع واكيد ان
عندما يطلعون حقيقه الاوضاع سيغيرون
مواقفهم ودليل على ذلك هو ان العديد ممن
اتخذ قرارات المواقف سلبيه في السابق يعني
راجعوا مواقفهم بل بالعكس يعني عبروا عن
استعدادهم لمواصله يعني دعم دعم المسيره
السياسيه في بلادنا ودعم الاقتصاد في
تونس
بتعتقد ان هناك مشكله في نقل الصوره
الحقيقيه لما يحدث في تونس للخارج من
يتحمل
مسؤوليتها هل بسبب ارتباط اطراف من
المعارضه مثلا من ابرزها حركه النهضه وهذا
ليس سرا ارتباطها تاريخيا باعلام لندن ثم
ايضا معارضه لها ارتباطات تاريخيه ايضا
باوساط فرنسيه لماذا ليس لديكم قدره على
اقناع عموم التونسيين العاديين غير
المسيسين في الوقت اللي ببدو انه هناك عجز
او فشل في نقل حقيقه الجدل القائم في تونس
للخارج
يعني هذه يعني شبكات عالميه اصبحت يعني
مسيطره على الاعلام في العالم واصبحت ما
يسمى بصناعه الراي العام
في مختلف البلدان اكيد انه لابد يعني من
اعداد استراتيجيه اعلاميه قادره على اعطاء
الصوره الحقيقيه بالنسبه للبلاد
ونستطيع القول واننا نجحنا وبدانا يعني
الخطوات الاولى في هذه الطريق وهو اعداد
الاستراتيجيه العالميه واكيد اننا بهاته
الاستراتيجيه الجديده نجحنا في تغيير
الصوره النمطيه التي وقع الدعايه
التشويقها ضد بلادنا
سوف نحاول في المستقبل دعم هذا التوجه
واعطاء الصوره الحقيقيه للوضع في تونس